Lots of work to be done by the runtime system, to manage and map_reduce
computation. The master data structures include the
location of files created by the completed mappers.
Remember that each mapper is working on
some node of the computational cluster. Producing
its output as files on its local disk. So the master has to have knowledge
of where those files reside. Created by those mappers, and the namespace of
the files that have been created by the mappers. And it also has to keep a score
board, of the mappers and reducers that
are currently assigned to work on different splits.
Because the number of machines that may be
available, may be less than the total number
of machines that will be needed. If I wanted to
do all of the input m splits in parallel and
all of the R output splits in parallel. And therefore,
the scoreboard is saying, at any point in time, who are
all the workers carrying all the mapper functions? Who are
all the workers carrying all the reducer functions? When are they
done? And when they are done. How should I reassign
that worker to a new task. So these are the kind
of things that the master data structures facilitate
the master to do. Then the big thing is
fault tolerance. For a variety of reasons, the
master may find, that an instance, of a map
function that it started, is not responding in
a timely manner. Maybe that node is down for
some reason, maybe the link is down for
some reason, or maybe that processor is taking a
little more time than what the master
expects. It can happen very easily, because in
a. Data center environment where you have
thousands of machines, there could be some machines
that are slower than other machines, there
could be generational differences between the machines that
populate the data center, even though they
may be homogenous in terms of the capabilities.
Programming alignments and even the machine architecture. They
may have speeds that are different because they
correspond to different generations of processes. In any
event, what might happen is that a master may
notice that there is no timely response from
a particular instance. Let's say of a mapper. In
that case, it might say well I'm going
to go ahead assume that that mapper is dead.
I'm going to restart that mapping function on
a different node of the cluster. Now, when
that happens it is possible that the original
mapper is actually dead, or it could be
that it was just slow. In that case,
you could get completion message from more than
one mapper for the same split. So when
you get multiple completion messages from redundant stragglers,
the master has to be able to filter
the mordancy. This is something that is redundant work.
I don't have to care about that. So that's
part of fault tolerance that the master has to
worry about. Locality management is another important thing. In
the memory hierarchy, making sure that the working set
of computations fit in the closest level of the
memory hierarchy of a process is very important, and
this is another thing that has to
be managed very carefully so that the computation
can make good forward progress. In completing the
map produce function. There is an inherent assumption
in the fault tolerance model of the
map produce framework. And that is item potency
of the mapper. That is, even though the same input data split is being worked on
by multiple mappers, It doesn't affect the
semantics of the computation as a whole,
and that is the reason why the
master can simply ignore the redundant stragglers'
message if in fact it was a slow computation engine that was working on a
particular map function. And if it finishes later than when it was supposed to,
and the master has already started another redundant
computation to take care of that particular split, ignoring that
redundant straggler message. Is okay because of the item potency assumption
about the mapping operation. In a similar manner, the master may assign a new
node to carry out reduced function corresponding
to a particular split if there's no timely
response from one of the reduced workers. And
here again, the output file generation that is
associated with a particular. A reducer split depends
on the atomicity of the rename system call
that is used to finally say that oh, this is the old profile generated, and the
master says okay, I'm going to commit this
as the real output file of the computation.
Each reducer is writing a local file, and
finally when the master gets the notification from
the reducer, that it has completed its work,
at that point, master renames that local file
as the final output file, and this is
where can get rid of redundant stranglers who
come along later and say I produce the
same output file for the same split. Master will
say, I already got it, I don't need this, and it can ignore the completion
message from that redundant straggler. The other
thing that the programming environment has to worry
about is locality management, and this is
accomplished using the Google file system that provides
a way by which, efficiently, data can
be. Migrated from the mappers to the reducers.
Task granularity is another important issue. As I
mentioned, the number of nodes available in the
computation cluster may be less than the sum M plus R, where M is the number
of input splits, and R is the number
of. Reducer splits. And it is the responsibility
of the programming framework to come up with
the right task granularity so that there can
be good load balance of the computational
resources. And the programming framework also offers
several refinements to the basic model. The
way the partitioning of the input data space
is done, is by using a hash function that is built into the programming
environment. But the user can override that
partitioning function with his or her own partitioning
function if they think that that'll result in
a better way of organizing the data. And
in the map reduced framework, there is no
interaction between the mappers, but if there's some ordering
guarantees needed in terms of ordering the keys
and so on, that is something that the user
may have to take care of. The other
thing that the user may also do is combining.
A partial merging to increase the granularity
of the tasks that execute a mapping function.
Remember that when we looked at the simple
example of looking for specific names and input
corpus of data, I mentioned that. The mapper can be as simple as emitting a one
for a value every time it encounters the
name Kishore for instance in an input file.
Or, it could take an input file and count
all the occurrences of Kishore in that input file
and finally emit the total value as the output
of the mapper. That kind of combining function is
something that. A user may choose to incorporate in
writing his mapping and reduce functions. It is very
important to recognize that in order for the fault
tolerance model of the programming environment to work correctly,
map and reduce functions have to be item potent.
That's a fundamental assumption. That the fault tolerant monitoring
of the programming framework is based on. And there
are also other bells and whistles in the programming framework
for getting status information and logs and so on
and so forth, but the basic idea I want to
leave you with is the fact that the programming
framework is a very simple one. It has two operations,
map and reduce and using those two operations. You can specify a
complex application that you want to call up, to run on a data
center, using the computation resources that's available in the data center.